we sifted through the list of upcoming
shows and tried to determine which ones
might not survive 2019 maybe it's a case
of a bad premise showrunners with awful
track records or just tired storylines
regardless this group of programs may
not be long for the televised world ABC
is no stranger to genre thrillers based
around supernatural events or characters
that of otherworldly powers in that vein
the alphabet network is bringing us
emergence about a police chief who finds
a mysterious young girl near the site of
a major accident that discovery leads to
a vast conspiracy surrounding the child
I found a kid at the crash site though
the idea of superhuman kids on
television is far from new networks
haven't had the best success with the
concept in recent years Fox tipped its
toes into the Marvel Universe in 2017
with the gifted a show about a family
that discovers it's children have the
mutant gene the show lasted two seasons
before getting canceled the network
tried again two years later with the
passage in which a federal agent
protects a young girl at the center of a
series of top-secret government tests
that show lasted 10 episodes before
getting the axe and when you realize
that ABC has struggled with some of its
other out-of-this-world sci-fi shows
like flash-forward or B it seems like
emergence could be headed for a
relatively quick disappearance ABC has
been riding a hot hand in recent years
with the works of Shonda Rhimes from
Grey's Anatomy to scandal - how to get
away with murder
shondaland is a world of televised the
lights they're also major hits now ABC
is hoping to replicate the same magic
with showrunner Kenya Varys who's
blackish scored well enough from the
parent Network to earn a spinoff grown
--is-- that airs on the Disney owned
cable channel freeform now comes mixed
ish a prequel of sorts to blackish the
show follows rainbow Johnson as she
recalls her childhood growing up in the
80s and the struggles of being a
mixed-race child in a world that can't
decide where she should fit in but
unlike Shonda Rhimes his shows which all
have vastly different premises and
storylines mixed ish seems kind of like
a third version of the same story it's
hard to imagine that viewers are
interested enough in the Johnson family
to want a third series about them
especially one that seems to simply
cover old ground the world smack
today did it you can tell me box is
hoping for a winner with its family
sitcom outmatched the show stars Jason
Biggs and Maggie Lawson as a
working-class New Jersey family with
four kids nothing remarkable they are
except three of those kids happen to be
geniuses Salieri in my own home I don't
know what any of that means
television has a storied history of
giving us precocious children at sitcoms
it's what helped make Joey Lawrence the
Olsen twins and the kids from Modern
Family household names but it's a fine
line that shows walk with young
characters everyone wants to be Stewie
Griffin few want to be Steve Urkel the
idea of smart aleck a super genius kids
feels like an immediate turnoff
unless you're a spin-off of the Big Bang
Theory stop us if you've heard this one
a hoity-toity tight from the big city
finds himself in a small town where he
has to absorb the culture shock and find
a way to assimilate or at least
tolerates a completely new way of doing
things this premise has worked to great
success in a number of shows now NBC is
hoping to find similar success with
perfect harmony
the single-camera sitcom stars Bradley
Whitford who's in the midst of a run on
the highly regarded The Handmaid's Tale
he also previously found big success on
the peacock Network as Josh Lyman on the
West Wing this time around wit bird is a
former Ivy League music professor who
finds himself working with the choir of
a small-town Church as you'd expect
there is a major clash of sensibilities
between Arthur Cochran and his new
musical charges behind the scenes the
hope is that Leslie wake Webster and
Jason Winer two of the forces behind
CBS's life and pieces can make the show
a hit but it will be a challenge to see
how they make this pretty specific take
on an old premise stick with TV
audiences no one could ever accuse CBS
of not giving their audiences what they
want if there's one thing the Tiffany
network is chock-full of it's crime and
courtroom dramas from the CSI and NCIS
franchises to Bowl and the good fight
CBS viewers probably have a good idea of
how scripted dramatic jurisprudence
works yet for those television Watchers
tired of seeing shows about the inner
workings of the legal system well here's
another show about the inner workings of
the legal system
all rise follows the day-to-day
challenges of judges and lawyers in Los
Angeles as they try to work within an
inadequate system attempting to deliver
justice all
trying to make sense of their own lives
in the process it's one thing to find a
winning formula and attempt to duplicate
it it's another to continually reheat
and rearrange the same ingredients and
try to call it a new dish
CBS recently cancelled the code after
just one season when that courtroom
drama failed to gain any traction will
all rise stand up and distinguish itself
or will it follow the same fate it's not
uncommon for American television
producers to look overseas to find
inspiration for domestic shows sometimes
it works and sometimes it doesn't
Israeli television seems to have created
a hitch with the Baker in the Beauty a
show about a humble Baker who falls in
love with and begins dating an
international supermodel the series was
popular enough that Amazon picked up the
show's first two seasons for
international streaming around the same
time the show was reportedly being
adapted by Universal Television for
American audiences and eventually
ordered two series for the fall season
in the American version the setting
moves to Miami but the main characters
being of Cuban descent
it's another in a string of ABC shows
featuring latina actors and characters
similar to Ugly Betty and Grand Hotel
yet while those other shows feature
familiar faces and star power to
potentially bring viewers the Baker in
the beauty stars a number of actors who
might not be well-known by a wide
audience can the power of this unlikely
love story be enough to attract Watchers
or is the American version of this
affair supposedly debuting mid-season
doomed to go up in smoke
in the 90s Fox scored big with the
x-files a series about a science-minded
FBI agent paired with a wild-eyed
believer in conspiracy theories as they
chased fantastical cases with a
supernatural tinge while you couldn't
exactly call Fox Mulder a religious
zealot his steadfast faith and forces
greater than mankind made for a
compelling back-and-forth with the more
staid and methodical Dana Scully with
evil CBS is attempting to resurrect a
similar dynamic the show centers on a
questioning female clinical psychologist
who teams up with a priest in training
and a blue-collar carpenter to probe a
backlog of the church's unexplained
phenomena I know you believe in this
stuff I don't if the premise feels more
than a little x-files II to you then
you're probably not alone the difference
is that the CBS iteration is likely to
have many more biblical references than
its pair
predecessor in and of itself that's not
a bad thing the network had a
long-running hit with touched by an
angel and it's done fairly well with the
series got friended me but it's worth
wondering if there will be an audience
for a show that fits science versus
religion in such a dramatic way without
a clear point of view to draw audiences
in religious beliefs tend to run a lot
deeper than beliefs in UFOs after all if
the show tries to pay equal lip service
to a doubter and a true believer then
it's fair to wonder who the show will
really be for audiences might not find
the show to be evil itself but they
might not think it's all that good
either networks are keen on building
sitcoms around popular comedians whether
up-and-coming funny people or venerable
entertainers that audiences know after
watching them for years Kenan Thompson
falls squarely in the latter category
the veteran funny man broke on to the
scene as a child actor in multiple
Nickelodeon shows before beginning his
run on Saturday Night Live in 2003 he
currently holds the record as the show's
longest tenured cast member some of the
more successful series built around
comedians draw from the performers work
life or personality some of the worst
tend to stifle an actor's creativity and
an effort to put them in a network
friendly box NBC hopes to avoid that
second category with the Kenan show on
the show Thompson will play a widowed
father of two dealing with an
overbearing father-in-law
a familiar premise at least nothing
about the concept seems particularly
awful but nothing about it seems all
that compelling either the idea of the
harried single dad trying to balance
work and home life has been done plenty
of times and it hasn't felt particularly
fresh since maybe my three sons part of
what's made Thompson a stalwart on SNL
for more than a decade and a half has
been his ability to play hilarious and
outrageous characters now it seems like
NBC is asking him to play a much more
sedate persona in a format that's been
done to death the show is not even out
yet but it kind of already feels like a
relic of the past the idea that robots
and other forms of artificial
intelligence will rise up and eventually
signal the destruction of mankind is an
idea as old as science fiction itself
wasn't seeing the video of robots doing
parkour and wondered if the nightmares
they've had about their own cyber base
demise were actually on the verge of
coming true
who hasn't stood on a street corner
screaming that sky
had become self-aware and that
terminators were coming for us all just
us okay
anyway box is hoping that you haven't
tired of stories of dystopian digital
futures with its new show next the
futuristic thriller stars John Slattery
as a tech entrepreneur who realizes that
an artificial intelligence application
he created could eventually lead to the
world's destruction in an era where we
already have smart homes our phones are
always listening to us and companies and
governments are doing who-knows-what
with the data it might be hard to get
viewers to worked up over the premise of
the show seriously have you kept up with
the news on this stuff this tech
dystopia looks too familiar we want to
see something with robots a son is being
asked to follow in his father's
footsteps the son rebels against being
pigeon-holed into a career that he
doesn't want reluctantly that son
eventually succumbs to his destiny
though it might be in a different way
than was originally envisioned many an
on-screen tale is told that story but
this fall when you tune into Fox's
prodigal son you'll be asked to consider
what if the family business was murder
good boy on the show Tom Paine plays the
son of a convicted serial killer asked
to track down other serial killers
imagine if Dexter's son eventually
became a homicide detective the show is
expected to have elements of dark comedy
which might work in its favor otherwise
this could end up is another in a long
line of homicidal maniac themed mystery
shows that get bogged down in the
premise that relies too heavily on a
weird father-son relationship and not
enough about catching the bad guys check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite stop or coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]